92 milliards de dollars c'est le montant
de la dette cumulée par le liban
actuellement englué dans une crise
financière et économique sans précédent
ce samedi le premier ministre hassan
diab a annoncé ce que la population
redoutait le pays n'est plus en mesure
d'honorer ses créances et se retrouve en
défaut de paiement
pour la première fois de son histoire
nos réserves en devises ont atteint un
niveau délicat
je sens le gouvernement libanais à
suspendre l'échéance du 9 mars en raison
de l'urgence d'utiliser ce montant pour
subvenir aux besoins fondamentaux des
citoyens libanais cette semaine
l'exécutif a réfléchi à des solutions
pour gérer une dette qui s'élève à 170 %
de son produit intérieur brut une
négociation avec les créanciers afin de
restructurer cette dette est désormais
envisagée sur la base des options et des
perceptions disponibles les
interlocuteurs ont décidé à l'unanimité
de soutenir le gouvernement dans toute
décision qu'il prend en matière de
gestion de la dette
à l'exception du remboursement des
dettes arrivant à échéance
marichal a atteint fille il est à noter
que la réunion s'est concentré sur la
mise en oeuvre du plan complet qui
repose sur des réformes financières
administratives et bancaires synchronisé
avec le plan économique et social
comme indiqué dans le communiqué
ministériel
alors que le pays est surendetté les
libanais manifestent pour dénoncer une
politique monétaire qu'ils estiment
injuste depuis septembre dernier
les banques ont imposé des seuils pour
limiter les retraits la population
redoute un effondrement du système
bancaire qui pourrait menacer les
économies de particuliers nous sommes
avec le peuple nous ne voulons pas
fermer les banques ce qui ferme les
banques sont des voleurs ceux qui
ferment les banques profitent de leur
fermeture
nous voulons pas fermer les banques
aujourd'hui nous réaffirmons notre refus
de ces politiques
nous ne sommes pas venus pour fermer les
portes de la banque ce sont eux qui ont
fermé les portes devant les citoyens ce
sont eux qui donnent aux citoyens 50 $
par semaine ou 50 dollars par mois et
ils en sont arrivés à un point où les
dix qui n'ont plus d'argent non ils ont
de l'argent il ya des dollars dans le
pays
les il laisse les bureaux de change
sucer le sang des gens et augmenter le
taux du dollar pour leur propre profit
à la demande de l'état libanais une
mission d'urgence du fmi étaient
présentes dans le pays le mois dernier
sans faire d'annoncés par la suite
plusieurs forces politiques notamment le
hezbollah se sont récemment opposés à
l'hypothèse d'un plan de restructuration
de la dette sous l'égide du fmi
[Musique]